The following is a production of Frank Defratis and the Internet Museum of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratus, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of April 12th, 1999.
I'm getting a little bit of a late start tonight.
It's almost midnight.
I took a little bit of time today to update the archive page with more past HoloTalk broadcasts.
So if you're interested in hearing some of the past shows that you may have missed over the last few weeks, I think it may go back into February.
If you scroll down the HoloTalk page, you will see a link for Past HoloTalk shows.
And if you click on that link, it will take you to the archive page.
Now I've got shows archived going all the way back to nineteen ninety-seven.
Uh but I've recently tonight updated that entire page with shows going back to February, which weren't archived on a weekly basis, but they're up there now.
So if you missed any shows since February, you can go back to the uh past HoloTalk page and catch up on what's been happening.
This week, uh as I mentioned last week when we had the guest Alan Rhodey, I wanted to take a little bit of time to talk about the test that I did here with the 15 milliwatt laser diode.
And um this test worked out really well, and I'm uh unfortunately I have not had a chance to shoot another hologram this week with it.
In fact, I wanted to do an eight by ten.
I have one eight by ten plate left.
But I'm going to hold off with that because next week, I believe on the fifteenth or sixteenth is the the delivery date on this, I'm getting a thirty-five milliwatt diode coming in, and if that proves to be successful uh shooting a small four by five inch hologram, then I may use the 35 milliwatt to uh shoot the eight by ten.
But in any case, I want to uh just give a little quick rundown this week on this 15 milliwatt laser diode.
Now, once you get up into the powers of 15 milliwatt um with helium neon lasers, it gives you the capability of doing some very nice creative work.
Uh the 5 milliwatt helium neon lasers are great for the classroom.
They're great to start out with holography.
Um there's uh I know there's a ton of things that you can do with a five milliwatt.
Uh my first five milliwatt that I had, I was actually doing multiple color reflection holograms uh using triethanolamine on four by five inch Agva plates back in the early eighties.
So there's a lot of things you can do with a four by five.
Uh the 15, when you get up into the tens and fifteen, especially the fifteens, uh I guess the most famous 15 milliwatt helium neon laser out there is the uh Spectrophysics Stabilite uh 124B, which I've uh also had in the mid-80s.
And I believe, I'm not absolutely certain, but I believe I may have paid like $4,900 uh for that stabilite when it was new from Spectrophysics with the uh tube uh the head and the power supply.
I'll have to go back and see if I can dig out that uh sales receipt for that because I think that goes back.
I think I got mine back in 84 or 85.
But there were a lot of uh very uh well-known holographic artists that were working around the uh 10, 12, 15 milliwatt range for many years and created beautiful, beautiful display uh artistic holograms using 15 milliwatts of power.
So it's it's very advantageous to us to be able to move up into these higher powers.
Now I know some of the uh holograms that are done for conventions, uh the large holograms that you see out there are using 50 milliwatts, so it's going to be interesting to see what this 35 milliwatt does, and this is really going to get us into the uh ballpark range of doing some very uh uh large-scale work.
I want to run down the prices for this.
Now, the 15 millilit laser diode that I have is putting out six hundred and thirty-five nanometers, so we're very close to the six thirty-three line of uh helium neon laser.
Um I don't think it's absolutely necessary to work with six hundred and thirty-five.
Everyone, when we were talking very early on about laser diodes saying it'll be great to get down around six hundred and uh thirty-three nanometers, and we're as close to it as we can with these laser diodes.
But the holographic emulsions are sensitive to a number of different wavelengths, for instance, uh the BB plates from Germany, and maybe also the Slavage materials as well.
Both have a spike in the response curve at 647 nanometers for krypton.
So whether you're working with a 635 nanometer diode or 650, uh 635 is going to put you two nanometers away from 633, 650 is going to put you three nanometers away from 647.
So you're in the ballpark for both of those.
The main difference, the main difference is what you're going to pay for the diode.
Now, this 15 millilit 635 nanometer diode was $550 assembled.
Now, the same amount of power, you're going to be able to do the same size holograms, you're going to get the same type of response for a 650 nanometer diode.
Let me run down some of these prices for you just to uh because I know someone's going to hear $550 and they're going to think, well, that's just putting us right back where we were before, where people couldn't afford the higher powered.
And $550 is a big chunk for some people, especially if you're doing this as an amateur or hobbyist.
That's a big chunk.
So let's take a look at this.
Now, say for instance that you want to put your own laser diode module together.
Here's what it's going to break down to for 15 milliwatts of power at 650 nanometers.
You're going to pay, and these are approximate prices, maybe a little bit more, a little bit less, but we're only looking at a few dollars.
We're not looking at hundreds, uh, maybe three dollars, five dollars, because they're all relatively the same price around.
You're going to pay $90 for the 650 nanometer diode.
That's the raw diode in the little brass housing.
These are tiny little things.
You have to be very careful working with them.
Always make sure you're grounded.
The slightest uh touch of static on a raw diode will absolutely fry it.
Don't even think about five watt uh five uh volts or anything like that.
You're just just you walking across the carpet and picking it up, you're gonna fry it.
So you have to be very careful if you're doing this.
I just wanted to put that in there.
$90 for the actual diode.
Now, on top of that, you're going to need a driver now the diode's going to have to be it's either soldered to the driver or some of the dryer drivers have little uh uh uh receptacles or what we call females uh that you can plug the male end of the diodes into right on the chip itself so that's going to run you 30 you're going to pay nine dollars for a colonnading lens to go into the housing excuse me and twenty dollars for the actual housing itself now add that up you've got 90 30 9 and 20 and you're going to pay $149 for a 15 milliwatt 650 nanometer diode.
Now if you'd like to move up to 20 milliwatts at 650 nanometers you can put one together yourself by adding about $65 onto the $90.
I think it's $155 for the actual diode.
So you're looking at $214 for 20 milliatts at $150.
That's that's a nice piece too.
Now you can also get these assembled if you've got a little bit more cash to spend and I'm not selling these I'm just trying to give people an idea of uh of what we can do and at what price because I'm comparing this to the $550 that was paid for the $635 nanometer 15 milliwatt.
So you're comparing $149 to $150 and you're still getting the same amount of power and your emulsion is still going to be just as responsive because it has that spike right there at 647 nanometers for krypton.
Now, if you want these already assembled, you're looking at uh let's see, I have it all written down here I'm I'm shooting this from the hip because, like I had said, it's almost midnight, and I don't want to go over too long with this, but uh assembled, you're looking at $185 for the 15 milliwatt 650, and you're looking at 245 dollars for the 20 milliwatt.
That means that diode module is going to come already assembled in the housing, the brass housing, it's going to have the colonnading lens, it's going to have the laser diode, it's going to have two pigtail wires coming out of it where you just hook a couple batteries up to it and run it.
Um I did not have any luck running it off of the power general power supply.
Now, I had someone send me an email saying that you know, but I think they misunderstood the web page that I put up, meaning that I was running it off of one of those drivers that you just plug into the wall.
No, this is a very high quality regulated switching DC power supply from Power General, and uh I did not get one image running uh that diode uh diode module off of that power supply.
And I was just uh doing everything as normal.
Uh we think possibly that the AC current going into these uh into these power supplies has to be very, very clean.
So we're going to put a scope on the AC power here in the studio and find out if there's a lot of noise in there.
You can't have a lot of noise.
So it looks like the batteries are the best bet.
And I also picked something up that I'm experimenting with.
Now it's uh running at half price for 1999, and it provides up to 20 hours runtime for C Ds that use two AA batteries.
You can charge this up to 500 times.
So I've been using it and it looks pretty good.
Um it'll put out uh I think I measured it at uh four point one eight volts when it was fully charged, and I just ran it until the diode actually uh just went out.
But you can charge it up to five hundred times.
So this may save you a lot of money uh on batteries as well.
And the number for that is twenty-three five oh five.
That's uh stock number twenty-three-five oh five portable CD power pack.
And it uh it's actually a little lead acid battery, and it's the size of a C D case.
That's how that's the size, it's very thin.
If you've got a C D case sitting there, take a look at it.
This battery is the exact same size.
And uh I've been running the Infinite or 200 off of that, uh, with very good results so far.
So there you have it, folks.
Uh there's a little bit of an update on the 15 milliwatt if you'd like to move up in power a little bit, and you've been working with a five milliwatt laser pointer, uh, you can see that it's uh I don't want to say inexpensive because that's a relative word for most people.
I don't want to assume that uh sitting here saying 149 dollars is inexpensive for some people because I know raising a family myself with three kids uh who are now grown, but I can remember the day when uh if I had a hundred and forty nine dollars it was going to go for sneakers, it wasn't going to go for a laser diode.
So uh that is relative to you, but it's very inexpensive uh considering what you would have paid for a 15 milliwatt uh Heaney laser and also what you would pay for even a used 15 milliwatt HeNE laser.
Um it's a great opportunity to move up.
And like I had mentioned, next week I will be getting in the 35 milliwatt diode, and I'm very, very excited uh to get in the uh lab and start working with that, as you can imagine.
And uh from there, who knows where it's going to go.
But we're going to continue building this and see where we can take it and take it one step at a time.
Uh small power increments and work with it and see how it works.
And who knows?
We could really be into some really interesting stuff here.
So I want to thank you for tuning in.
Uh, we'll get back to more guests.
I'm going to go in and check the list of uh guests that I have uh scheduled for the rest of the season, send a couple emails out and get a few uh few new guests on the show.
And don't forget if you'd like to uh check out the Holo Talk Past broadcast, just scroll down the Holo Talk page and click on that link, and it will take you to an archive of previous broadcasts going all the way back to 1997.
So thank you very much for tuning in this week and every week.
I hope you continue to come back for news and information and guests concerning the fields of lasers and holography right here on the internet with HoloTalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show.
This is Frank Defratis.
Thank you for tuning in, and I'll see you next week.
Would you like to make your own one of a kind hologram and learn how you can start making holograms on your own at the same time?
You can do this and much more by attending one of Frank the Fratis's holography workshops.
From beginner to advance, Frank's got a workshop that's just right for you.
From single afternoon, evening, or weekend introductory workshops to Wednesday evening five-week complete courses.
And don't forget his newest workshop, Laser Pointer Holography.
Located just off the northeast extension of the Pennsylvania Turnpike and Interstate 78.
The studio is a quick nonstop drive from the New York, Philadelphia, and Baltimore, Washington, D.C.
areas.
For more information, call the studio's toll-free hotline at 1-800-458-3525 and begin your own journey with holography today.
That's 1-800-458-3525.
For more information on attending Frank De Freitas Holography Workshop today.